هل هنالك مجموعه من الصواريخ عثمان تنطلق
من شمال قطاع غزه
نعم هذا هذه الصواريخ الان على مقربه منا
في منطقه ازديراب وفي منطقه اياد الكبيره
تنطلق من غزه هذه
الصور تاتين مباشره
من غزه اذا وهي ضمن رشقات صاروخيه متتاليه
اطلقتها في الساعات الماضيه فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعثمان
وهذا يتزامن يتزامن مع يتزامن مع صافرات
انذار بالفعل في منطقه ازديرات وايفيم
ونير عام
ووابل من الصواريخ في تلك المنطقه نشاهدها
الان ربما كنتم تشاهدون قبل قليل
الى ان هذه الصور تاتينا من غزه لرشاقات
الصواريخ التي تطلقها في الصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في ذات الوقت نحن نستمع الى
صوت زميلنا الياس كرام الذي يحدثنا من
الجانب الاخر في جنوب
عسقلان اذا انت هناك الياس
نعم وهذا ما كنا نتحدث عنه بالفعل عثمان
عن وابل كثيف الان ايضا من الصواريخ تطال
منطقه
ناحيه العوز ومنطقه نيتيف عصره كل المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه لقطاع غزه
تعرضت لهذه الرشقه الصاروخيه وكانت هنالك
اعتراضات ايضا في تلك المنا